we live in the digital age which means
we can download most games directly onto
our consoles instead of trekking to the
local store but what games get the most
downloads thanks to a post from the
PlayStation Blog we now know the top 20
best-selling ps4 games on PSN 4 2015
counting down from 20 to 1 the top games
for the US are metal gear solid 5
resident evil dragon ball xenoverse
batman arkham knight battlefield 4
rocket league madden NFL 16 battlefield
hardline fifa 16 dying light blood-borne
the Elder Scrolls online Mortal Kombat X
The Witcher 3 destiny fallout 4 star
wars battlefront minecraft grand theft
auto 5 and call of duty black ops 3 it's
also interesting to note that minecraft
made the list for ps4 ps3 and Vita not a
bad year for the block builder the
PlayStation Blog also released lists for
the top-selling games on ps3 and Vita
we've posted all the rankings on
gamespot check it out then stick around
for all the PlayStation news and reviews
you could want